[Music]
yeah ethical known monogamy e m the
practice of taking part in romantic
relationships that are not completely
exclusive between two people I uh
have also
I've had friends female friends ask me
if I'd be into
um what is it called
ethical co-parenting or something like
that yeah basically like hey I'm still
single and I don't have a kid
Ben do you want to have a kid with me
what movie is that
I don't know what [__] movie is that
it's not knocked up it's I'm pretty sure
it's the guy in you know what I'm not
even gonna try and do this because it's
gonna be embarrassing
but it is a movie that's a plot of a
movie that exists and uh they seem like
they had it they had a good time where
they just decided hey we're gonna have a
kid as friends yeah huh that sounds fun
yeah
I still don't know if I want a kid
really yeah with my most recent ex it
was a point of contention because she
wanted kids no she didn't she said she
didn't and you did yeah and I was well
you just said you're not sure well I I
mean it changes and last summer I was
thinking I definitely want a kid I
definitely want one and I brought it up
as like uh hey maybe
um and I do this I tend to do this if if
I haven't thought out
a Feeling
I will just talk it out stream of
Consciousness style and for her it could
be upsetting and I guess it was because
I was like yeah maybe I wouldn't maybe I
need to be with someone who wants a kid
it was like
uh yeah yeah uh because this is the most
recent one oh so this is the reason why
no no that's not why but uh yeah she was
like why um what if you end up with
someone who also wants kids but then
they can't have them like what are you
gonna do then leave that person and go
find someone who can have them and I was
like yeah that's a good point that's a
really good point but uh yeah I still I
still I'm I'm on the fence there's an
entire subreddits I think there's one
called on the fence about people just
like that who aren't sure and there's
one called regretful parents
oh you know really yeah they just like
hate their kids they [__] they're
I've seen guys who are just like their
whole their whole yeah here's oh fence
fence go to regretful yeah regret there
was one guy who just said uh I remember
him saying like I wake up every day and
hate my life I hate my children and he's
got like three of them
um what yeah well search by like the the
top of all time I wonder what it is you
don't want to believe that this exists
especially when you're like about to
actually have a kid sure like like I'm
not saying we're like pregnant or
anything but enough to saying like I
definitely want to have a kid soon yeah
and but you want like you know you're
still I feel like everyone is sort of a
fence sitter in this phase where it's
like oh maybe not now maybe you know
you're still kind of like kind of
hanging on to your Independence a little
bit even though you're like starting to
be like no I gotta live for someone else
yeah at this point but
um how you want to believe that you know
there is that like immediately that
magic is like what you hear from every
single parent where it's like I would
trade everything just for this because
it's like it's a magic you'll never know
and you know everything you hear from
parents and then you read stuff like
this and you're like [__] there's a
chance that this could happen yeah my
dad when I was um I think I might have
talked about this on on trillionaire but
uh my dad when I was a year old wrote
hand wrote me a letter
for future me and uh I opened it after
he died and it was like four pages four
or five pages long and it was very
interesting because he was around my age
now writing this to to Baby me saying
how much he just was like in love with
being a parent loved me you know
couldn't wait for me to get older so we
could be buddies and sent me this whole
time capsule like gas receipt uh grocery
store receipt
um what was playing in the movie
theaters that week uh you know all sorts
of [__] and I still have it and yeah
once every couple years I pop it out and
look at it and read it and that kind of
thing yeah that kind of
I I share his enthusiasm for yeah
wanting to be a dad so Pro tip for
anybody who is uh expecting a kid or
thinking about it definitely do
something like that hand write your kid
your future kid a letter because man
that's awesome it it's a a really really
special thing me uh Kelsey and I were
like
filming like you know some some like
small stuff at our wedding and stuff
like that for our future kiss that's
[__] cool man I love that one time I
got high and uh I was by myself this is
when I was in my early 20s and I was at
home and uh I was just like you know
what I'm gonna write a letter to my
future kid and start writing it and then
I like trailed off and got distracted
and I found it years later it just was
like dear future son or daughter if you
are not my future sonar daughter [__]
you this isn't for you stop reading and
then it was like yeah this is just who I
am like it was [__] stupid and
embarrassing anyway I'll tell you about
this [__] Volvo that I own all right
this [__] thing
in love with this Volvo yeah
look look at this one husband finally
admitted to Baby trapping me Jesus
Christ
wait what a keep keep scrolling let's
see I want to see a couple others here
uh no no that's not juicy enough [__]
autism not juicy enough
uh oh this is this is interesting why
discourage parenting in 10 bullet points
let's see this number one it is
expensive number two stresses out of
this world it never ends until you die
did I mention the cost you used to just
work now you do school runs and medical
appointments on top of work you and your
spouse may fall out of love and no
longer want to be together well those
little bundles of Joy will not make life
any easier splitting up
oh God yeah your kids May develop any
number of problems enjoy their Surly
teenager years loudmouth friends and
partners I mean I it's hard you know
sure there's a comment because we're not
in this situation at all but you have to
there's you have to think somewhere in
the back your mind like it'll get better
right
maybe not I mean maybe
if you have a child I don't know
you know I don't know I think but like
you have to think like at some point
they're gonna be adults they're gonna be
making their own money and at that point
it's like yeah sure maybe you like
regret 15 or 18 years of your life or
whatever but like maybe you'll be best
friends with them maybe they'll grow up
to be a [__] rock star and they'll
buy you a house right for me the risk is
the pain of losing them to sickness or
death or anything but
one thing that I've learned learned in
my uh romantic Endeavors avoiding love
and avoiding the closeness of a
relationship just because of your fear
of eventually losing them is no way to
live life yeah oh they might die they
might leave me like okay so you deprive
yourself of that experience to begin
with yeah yeah of course just so you
don't have to deal with that that
Fallout that's uh that's uh you know
you're living scared that's not the way
to go yeah and I I did that in my late
20s and early 30s and was like uh this
person could [__] get sick and die or
I could die and it would devastate them
better better keep one foot out the door
just in case yeah yeah better is that
your reservation right now is that why
you're no no not at all I've grown out
of that I've embraced it and been like
okay you know what it's all about
leaning into it and embracing that
vulnerability and uh really giving
yourself to to another person and
relishing in that for as long as the you
Universe grants it to you because yeah
you could wake up dead tomorrow or you
could live to be you're gonna wake up
Dad no I know it's an old Simpsons joke
Homer says it's a Bart it's so great
yeah you could wake up dead tomorrow but
uh yeah you you never know what's gonna
happen so you might as well enjoy what
you got while you've got it um
but
yeah I I definitely
um I'm of the attitude of fully leaning
in now and just
give it to me that's good and then it
sucks you know when when [__] does
happen and you can't [__] really yeah
but that's life heartbroken yeah that's
sad did you guys have I feel like the
older I get the more I'm just like oh no
this is the point of life yeah yeah
totally what else is there to travel
it's like to travel and eat good food
with your spouse
yes yes
there are yes things too
but
what I was just saying there is another
side of like if
you know you live no I know there's
another side and I just like I just I
just disagree with it like like right
now as far like from my perspective I'm
like the I don't know the older I get
the more I'm like okay this is like I I
feel selfish like hmm it's continuing to
keep just only be concerned about me
you know what I mean I think it's kind
of weird maybe that's like just because
I've started to like Care for Animals
and stuff like that I'm slowly learning
like oh no there is this other really
fulfilling part of life where it's like
you give yourself to others
and I do still want to Chase my dreams
and stuff but I feel like and of course
I'm in like a pretty privileged position
where I do you know I can
have the you know money to do stuff like
that and have help and stuff like that
but I do I want to like I just feel like
I want to you know help I don't know
like live for something else sure it is
the uh it's the ultimate um it's the
ultimate Marathon yeah yeah true yeah
it's the next big step man you you do a
uh you do an Iron Man and you gotta do
the iron Dad after that yeah I mean I
think of uh have you ever seen Raising
Arizona
uh no
you should what it's one of the best
it's the Coen Brothers It's one of their
first movies it's a young Nicholas Cage
and it's so fun it's about this couple
who can't the the woman is Barren and
she can't have a kid and um
they they kidnap a child and and a
baby's cage yeah they kidnap a baby and
at the very end
there's this like dream sequence where
they're they're an old couple and
they've all they want is to start a big
family and have kids and have grandkids
and stuff and uh at the very end
um they've there's it's like a dream
sequence where they've somehow managed
to overcome nature and have a big family
and it's just really sweet because they
got their kids and grandkids all around
the like dinner table and stuff and that
seems nice